c'est la réunion de deux amis vincent et
xavier ont fréquenté le même lycée dans
leur jeunesse à la celle-saint-cloud
après des carrières respectives dans la
musique les yvelinois se retrouvent et
font de macadam crocodiles le duo était
de retour à cannes pour se produire dans
l'une des soirées du 62e festival comme
il ya un an c'était sur la terrasse du
five six hôtels c'est toujours sympa de
venir parce que on recroise plein de
gens qu'on ne voit pas forcément pendant
qu'on est en tournée il ya plein d'amis
musiciens la comen et d'un television ya
plein de gens qu'on croise sur la route
et puis voilà il ya un petit esprit
festif qui peut bien correspondre à
mcadam d'une certaine manière dont
l'emplacement
non mais la musique a clairement sa
place à cannes notamment dans les
soirées macadam crocodile c'est un style
basé sur des prestations en live mêlant
chants et instruments le tout au rythme
de l'électro du new disco et de l'afro
funk
cette année le groupe a franchi une
étape dans son projet un album a été
enregistré en avril dans un club
parisien
au lieu de se dire on va sortir un album
de manière un peu classique on s'est dit
que ce qui correspondrait peut-être
mieux c'était d'enregistrer en fait un
live et de ce live soit l'album en fait
et donc c'est ce qu'on a fait au mois
d'avril long avril on arrose trio
badaboum à paris à paris et on était
très très sûr plier ses sapins fois
qu'on vous ait une salle en tête
d'affiche et on
une led la lui répondant il y avait on
avait un super accueil du monde qui est
venu cet album en live devrait sortir
d'ici la fin de l'année ou début 2011
[Applaudissements]